and breaking news
england have beaten germany in their
euro
2020 match tonight at wembley raheem
sterling scoring the first goal in the
first half
of the match and harry kane scoring the
second let's go
live now to our correspondents ashna
harinag who's in trafalgar square
tom palmenta at wembley let's go to
ashna first i can see
everyone's so elated behind you
there is no doubt the crowd here are
completely
elated by the scenes they've just seen
if i step out the way
as soon as we saw those last two goals
the pints
went flying you can see a huge crowd in
the middle there
flags being waved around people with
their arms in the air
screaming for joy you can see also the
press surrounding them it's no doubt
that
these pictures are the ones that you are
going to see across the front rages
tomorrow morning
there is unbridled joy this is a fan
zone that has been filled with
about 850 england fans and it has to be
said that the national team certainly
delivered tonight with goals from rush
from sterling i should say but also um
harry kane
they were really um extremely excited so
much those are announcing
still and now also telling people to get
back into their bubbles and telling
people to try and calm down and and
apply
social distancing it has to be said that
a lot of these benches
are set out for that purpose during the
game itself people were socially
distanced but
with the joy of the game comes of course
a little bit of alcohol within that and
people
are celebrating uh within that space
there
um there is no doubt that for many
england fans they are used to the ups
and downs of this beautiful game
um but today the national team brought
home that victory that many of them
sought after
many of the fans that i was speaking to
earlier on uh thought that actually we
would enter extra time and then we might
end up going into penalties
and many hope that they wouldn't see a
replay of the 1996
euro torn one where of course gareth
southgate missed a penalty
but these are the scenes uh which will
be
felt right across the nation not only in
pubs and bars
but in parks and in venues like this
where
fans are celebrating
okay ashley thank you well we can see
how
excited the england fans are let's take
a look at how german
germany fans are responding these are
pitchers coming to us
from berlin that's when they were
watching the match
as it was unfolding clearly despondent
there as uh
england beat germany 2 nil tonight with
goals from raheem sterling
and harry kane